Hello, my name is
Dr. Sonia Rivera
-Martinez and I'm
Associate Professor
of the Department
of Family Medicine.
I am here to
speak to you today
about the history
and physical exam
of the gastrointestinal
system.
The session objectives
for today's lecture
is identify and describe
the components of
a history for a common
gastrointestinal
complaint. We will
describe the components and
sequence of a physical
exam of the abdomen,
define and describe
and identify the
different types of
bowel sounds, identify
and discuss normal
examination findings,
and then list
and describe the
documentation and
history and physical
exam for the
gastrointestinal system.
We have a case
presentation of a 44
-year-old female
with a complaint of
constipation which
has been worsening
over the past three
to four months.
What questions should
you ask this patient?
Any questions
pertaining to
osteopathic principles
and practice?
During your
history taking,
consider the
patient's discomfort
in reporting
certain complaints.
We will look into the
definitions of
constipations.
Physicians consider
constipation to be
fewer than three bowel
movements per week.
Patients, however,
consider constipation
to be production of
hard stools, a feeling
that they have an
incomplete evacuation,
excessive straining,
a sense of ****
****** blockage
during defecation,
and sometimes the
need for manual
maneuvers to be
able to ********.
For history taking,
particularly for the HPI,
the items that you
should be considering
in the onset, when
did it start? If it is
an older person,
consider cancer. What are
the palliating and
provocation factors?
What have they tried?
Also have them
describe the quality
of their stools
and whether or not
they're having the
sensations that we
talked about,
excessive straining,
and which of these
symptoms are the most
distressing to the
patient. This is very
important. The severity
of these symptoms,
how frequent they
are, what are the
intervals between
bowel movements,
whether they
experience prolonged
straining or need
digital evacuation,
use of laxatives
and how often
do they use them,
the sensation
of incomplete evacuation,
and you'd also want
to know the timing.
Does it occur
intermittently and
how many bowel
movements per week?
For associated
symptoms, you would
want to ask at
least fever, nausea,
if there's any
abdominal pain.
If it alternates with
diarrhea, then consider
it might be irritable
bowel syndrome.
If they have
paradoxical diarrhea,
particularly in the
elderly, consider
***** impaction,
bloating and cramping,
irritable bowel syndrome,
blood in the stools,
consider colon
cancer, particularly
in the elderly,
diverticulosis or even
inflammatory bowel
disease which includes
Crohn's disease and
ulcerative colitis,
and any weight loss
over 10 pounds,
particularly if it is not
intentional, colon
cancer. Other items to
consider are pain with
digital ****** exam.
You would think
of possibly an
**** fissure
or hemorrhoids.
Leakage of stool.
Perhaps there might
be ***** impaction
or ****** prolapse.
Also look into
medications. Common
ones that cause
constipation are
opioids, calcium
channel blockers,
and iron supplements.
In the past medical
history, look into
Parkinsonism,
hypothyroidism, and dementia
as common causes
for constipation.
Other causes of
constipation include
reduced physical
activity. This is for this
reason that you
would want to counsel
your patients to
increase their physical
activity if they
suffer constipation.
Find out about a
history of being
bedridden for more
than two weeks. This is
common in patients
who are hospitalized
but sometimes also
bedridden at home.
Look into post
-surgical. Many of
the medications
that are given
for surgery do
cause constipation.
Look into the history
of any dietary changes
that the patient may
have had recently,
particularly
find out how much
fiber is included
in their diet.
It is also important
to look at dehydration.
A lot of individuals
do not drink
sufficient fluids
and this is also
a common cause
for constipation.
Examine for electrolyte
disturbances,
whether or not
there is *****
impaction. This occurs
frequently in the
elderly but not
exclusively, and also
if there is intestinal
obstruction.
We will now pass
on to discuss
anatomy and how
it relates to
gastrointestinal
complaints.
For examination purposes,
we divide the abdomen
in four quadrants.
This is general but
there's more than one
type of way that
we can discuss and
identify the different
places in which abdominal
pain or the complaints
might occur.
Now in this case we
have four quadrants.
The right upper
quadrant, left upper
quadrant, right lower
quadrant, and left
lower quadrant. As
you can see on the
illustration, each of
these quadrants have
different anatomical
structures related
to that particular
anatomical quadrant.
Here is a table with
contents for each
quadrant. This is
for you to review.
There are some that you
will readily identify,
such as the liver
and the gallbladder
in the right upper
quadrant in the left
upper quadrant you
will find spleen and
stomach left right lower
quadrant the appendix
left lower quadrant
the sigmoid colon etc
here is another way of
dividing the abdomen
this is now in nine
regions in which
you have right and left
hypochondriac region
meaning below the rib,
epigastric region,
right and left lumbar
region and umbilical
region, and then you
have the right and
left iliac region and
hypogastric region.
Here is another table
with contents for the
different regions of
the nine area system.
You can go ahead
and study these so
you can get
familiarized with what
is inside each one
of these regions.
This is a
continuation of the
previous table
with contents.
Here is a region that
you should be familiar
with. It's the costal
vertebral angle.
It defines where you
can access the kidney
for tenderness. The
angle is formed by the
lower border of the 12th
rib and the transverse
processes of the upper
lumbar vertebrae.
This is an important
anatomic location.
There is a specific
testing that
is done in this
area for costal
vertebral angle
tenderness.
We will now go
on to discuss
the examination
techniques.
For examination of
the abdomen, this
is the order in
which it must occur.
First you inspect,
second you
auscultate, then you
perscuss, and lastly
you will palpate.
Make sure that you
know this very well. It
must occur in this
order because doing
palpation or percussion
before you auscultate
will alter the way that
the intestinal sounds
will be. We'll discuss
that more later.
In preparing for
the abdominal exam,
your room should
have good light,
it should be
warm, all of your
instruments and your
hands should be warm.
The patient, you
should have them in
a position that they
are most relaxed.
Put in pillow or
folded sheets under
the heads and the
knees. The knees
slightly bent so it
makes it easier to
examine the abdomen
in that manner.
The abdomen will not
have tense muscles,
have the patient's
arms at his
sides or his her
sides. The exposure,
place the drapes
appropriately. You want to
be able to see everything
from just below
the ******* to just
above the ***** bone.
Have the patient
empty their bladder
before the
examination and
remember this last
important thing.
If the patient
is coming in with
pain you should
examine the
area of pain last.
Remember that.
Examine the area of
pain last. That is
to minimize discomfort
to the patient.
We will now go on to
do each part of the
abdominal exam starting
with inspection.
When you're
inspecting the abdomen
of a patient, the patient
should be lying
supine or face up.
The abdomen should
be completely exposed
as mentioned in the
previous slides.
It should reveal all four
quadrants. Tell
your patient that
you're inspecting
their abdomen.
You can let them
know that you're
inspecting the
abdomen and then
tell them what
you're looking for.
You always remember
that you want to
observe from the right
side of the patient.
You're going to
inspect the abdominal
wall. You're
going to look for
symmetry in any
masses that might be
present on the
skin. Look for any
scars, striate,
dilated veins, rash,
lesions, discoloration.
You or pulsations
that might be present
during your observation
when inspecting the
abdominal wall contour
you're going to look
for things such as
distension whether or
not this distension is
generalized or localized
each one of these
would mean different
types of diagnoses
whether or not their
abdomen is protuberant
scaphoid or flat all
of those would have
clinical significance
if there are any
masses present on
the abdominal wall
you want to inspect
them from different
angles from
left, right, caudid,
cephalod views.
You also want
to distinguish
between an abdominal
wall mass or
an intra-abdominal
wall mass.
You want to inspect
the abdomen for scars.
When scars are present,
you should diagram
them or describe them
within the chart. In
your description include
the location, the
shape, the size
measured in centimeters,
the type whether or
not if it is surgical
or an injury, and
the healing stage.
Next you want to
make sure that you
correlate this with
patients history.
Oftentimes they do not
remember about surgeries
that occurred when
they were young.
I also wanted to take
note that there's
many notes that are
listed within the notes
section for each
slide. Make sure you
review those documents
there because more
explanation will be
included in those notes.
You want to also
inspect the abdomen
for striae. STRI
-A are related
to rupture of
reticular dermis with
the rapid stretching
of the skin.
This occurs very
commonly in multiple
disorders such as
Cushing syndrome,
Erlostandrin syndrome,
and ascites,
overuse of
cortisone. It is also
present in other
times of the patient
when there is
obesity, there's
pregnancy, or even
during puberty.
These may have
clinical significance
when they are related to
certain syndromes
as listed here.
You want to inspect
the abdomen for
any dilated veins
that are present.
A few veins that are
small and visible,
they're generally
considered normal.
However, abnormal
dilatation can
be seen in portal
hypertension,
emaciation,
or in IVC obstruction.
These are
important. Here is a
clear illustration
of something
that is called
kaput medusa.
As with many
other regions of
the body, you want
to inspect the
abdomen for any
skin lesions.
As with these scars,
you need to describe
the location, the
size, the color, the
shape, and the pattern
of distribution.
These may very well
be correlated with the
patient's current
symptoms, so it's
important that you do
make notation of them.
Inspect the abdomen
for discoloration.
Here we list two
signs that are related
to discoloration.
In the Cullen sign,
you will see
periumbilical ecchymosis.
This usually tells
you that there
is hemoperitoneum
or bleeding.
In the Grace-Turner sign,
the ecchymosis is
located in the flank
region. This would
indicate retroperitoneal
bleed. Both of
these signs are
omnias for the patients
so pay very close
attention to the
presence of these.
Next you will look for
jaundice in the abdomen.
Generally there
is the presence of
jaundice. You would
look into three
different types,
the pre-hepatic,
the hepatic, and
the post-hepatic.
In the pre-hepatic,
the blood cells
would rupture faster
than the liver can
conjugate bilirubin.
In the hepatic,
the liver's inability
to conjugate or
excrease bilirubin
is the cause of the
jaundice. And in the
posthepatic, the flow
of bile into the
intestines is blocked.
All three of these
are distinct and
have different lab
values you want to
inspect the abdomen
for the umbilicus
and observe its
contour the location
whether or not it's
inflamed any bulges
that might indicate
the presence of
a hernia and also
the location can
all can be correlated
to the presence
of masses or other
occurrences within
the abdomen.
Look into inspecting
the abdomen
for the
respiratory motion.
Absence of respiratory
motion in all or
part of the abdominal
wall suggests peritoneal
irritation and this
would also be present
in acute abdomen.
Respiratory alterans
or paradoxical, in which
you would see either
alternating outward
and inward displacement
of the abdomen
during respiration,
indicating the diaphragm
muscle is fatigued.
And then you would also
can see paradoxical
inward displacement
with inhalation, and
that might indicate
the presence of COPD.
Inspect the abdomen
also for pulsations
and peristalsis.
You might be able
to view an abdominal
aortic aneurysm
that might be visible
as a pulsatile
mass. This would
be in a very thin
person or in the
presence of emaciation.
You might also see
visible peristalsis. Here
I include a video that
shows it markedly.
Next we will discuss
auscultation and
common findings
that you made here
during auscultation
of the abdomen.
Auscultation of
the abdomen. This
is a reminder to
auscultate the abdomen
before percussion
or palpation.
These maneuvers may
alter the frequency
of bowel sounds. So
remember, inspect,
auscultate before
percussion or palpation.
You want to place
the diaphragm of your
stethoscope very
gently up the abdomen.
This is very important,
particularly if
you are examining somebody
that does complain
of pain. Listen for
bowel sounds. Note
their frequency and
character and you
also want to listen
for vascular fluids.
Remember to
auscultate all
four quadrants
of the abdomen.
Normal active
bowel sounds. The
estimated frequency
is 5 to 34
clicks or gurgles
per minute.
Bowel sounds
are produced by
peristalsis of
the intestines.
They occur intermittently.
They're low
-pitched, chuckling.
There are other
descriptions of the
sounds that occur with
peristalsis and that
you will end up finding
in your auscultation
of the abdomen.
When bile sounds
are hypoactive, this
is referred to as
reduction in the
loudness, tone,
or regularity. Now
remember that within
normal you have
the lowest number
is 5 per minute.
The sign that intestinal
activity has slowed
can be related to
being normal which
occurs during sleep
after the use of certain
medications such as
opioids and anesthetics
and after abdominal
surgery. This is where
the abdominal sounds
would be hypoactive.
They may
indicate also the
presence of ileus
which is failure
of peristalsis,
peritonitis,
bowel obstruction,
constipation,
and electrolyte
imbalances.
When the bowel sounds
are hyperactive this
is due to increased
intestinal activity.
Sometimes it can't
be heard without a
stethoscope. I'm
pretty sure that all
of you familiar
with those sounds,
occurs with diarrhea
and often after eating.
There are disease
states that do
have hyperactive
bowel sounds such as
Crohn's disease and
ulcerative colitis,
gastrointestinal
bleeding,
enteritis,
early bowel obstruction,
and in laxative use.
The absence of bowel
sounds, in order
for you to state
this, you must
listen the abdomen
for a full two to
three minutes before
making the statement
that the bowel
sounds are absent.
This may occur
after or with ileus,
bowel obstruction,
necrosis of bowel
tissue, or peritonitis.
So be careful.
These sound very obneous,
all of these disorders.
Make sure you do
listen to the two
two to three minutes
before you make
this diagnosis or
document this finding.
There are other bowel
sounds that can't
be present in the
abdomen. We have
borborygmy, which
are prolonged gurgles
of hyperperistalsis.
You can refer these
as the stomach
growling or rumbling.
And then you have
high-pitched tinkling
sounds. This is
suggestive of dilated
bowel due to the
presence of air and fluid
under tension. So
if you hear this,
this would be another
one that's omnius.
And then you would
hear rushes of high
-pitched sounds that
coincide with abdominal
cramps. This can
be suggestive of
intestinal obstruction.
Remember that all
of these must be
correlated with the
patient's complaints
and your history
and physical examination
of the patient.
Ascultate the
abdomen for vascular
bruies. Bruies resemble
very much heart
murmurs. Check the
area of the aorta,
renal, iliac, and
femoral arteries.
Presence of these
bruies are suggestive
of renal artery
stenosis, which would
be a secondary cause
of hypertension,
arterial insufficiency,
and arterial occlusion.
Ascultate the
abdomen also when
you're listening
for friction rubs.
This is rare in
occurrence, may
be found over the
liver or spleen.
This implies
that the surface
of the organ
is irregular.
A rub is caused
by the grating of
inflamed peritoneal
surface against
each other during
respiration. There
can be involvement
of tumor abscess
or infarction when
this is present.
We will now move on to
discussion of percussion.
Percussion of the
abdomen. You want
to make sure
that you percuss
all four quadrants
of the abdomen.
Assess for tympani
and dullness.
Usually you're
going to find
that tympani
predominates.
There may be some
small areas of
dullness, that would
be normal, but note
that any large area
of dullness may
indicate a mass or
an enlarged organ,
such as in a female,
enlarged uterus,
an enlarged liver
in either female or
male, and also an
enlarged spleen. All
of these can be found
with percussion.
The liver is one
of the organs
that you want to
do percussion and
you're going
to do this from
the mid clavicular line.
You're going to
percuss the liver
in a downward or
upward direction.
Start at the area below
the embolicus at the
mid-calicular line and
percuss up from the
abdominal tympani until
dullness is appreciated
around the lower
boulder of the liver.
That's what this
would indicate, the
lower border of the
liver. Next, you
starting from the
****** percuss a
line from the lung
resonance down towards
the liver dullness.
This would give
you the upper
border of the liver.
When dealing with the
patient with large
breasts, you want
to ask her or him to
displace the breast as
necessary. Then you from
the area that you
finished percussing from
the upper border to
the lower border,
you want to measure
that in centimeters and
and that will determine
whether or not the
size of the liver is
normal or enlarged.
Here we have an
illustration of the normal
liver span from the
midclavicular line.
It would be customarily
from 6 to 12
centimeters in the right
midclavicular line.
The illustration also
points to there is
four to eight
centimeters at the mid
-sternal line. We do
not measure the expand
of the liver at the
mid-sternal line. The
customary place to
do the liver spine to
the thermon, if it's
enlarged or not, is
from the mid-clavicular
line. Repeat,
measure from the lip
mid-clamicular line.
The next organ that is
customarily percussed
is the spleen. The
spleen, when you are
percussing, you're
going to do this from
the anterior lateral
aspect of the abdomen,
not directly on the
front of the abdomen.
Percuss from the
lowest interspace in
the left anterior
axillary line, it should
be tympanetic. Ask
the patient to take
a deep breath and
percuss again. It
should stay tympanetic
if it is not enlarged.
If it becomes dull
upon inspiration,
this might suggest
splenic ***********.
These are illustrations
of where the
anterior axillary
line would be
located and where
you would do your
percussion for the
spleen. It also shows
the difference of
what would occur
when the spleen
is not enlarged
versus it being
enlarged and
which you would
be able to percuss
during inspiration,
if it is enlarged.
If you detect
any abdominal
masses by percussion,
these are some of
the items that would
be considered
depending on the area
that the abdominal
mass might be located.
Remember that this
is that when you
percuss, you would
find a large area
of dullness. In the
right upper quadrant,
you might consider
a large liver,
high drops of the
gallbladder, or carcinoma
of the head of the
pancreas, again
depending on where
the mass would be
located. If it is
epigastric, consider
pseudocyst or carcinoma
of the pancreas,
or gastric malignancies
or even colon
malignancies in
the flank there might
be the presence
of a cyst or a tumor
if you look at the
left upper quadrant
there might be in the
large spleen or carcinoma
of the stomach or
colon if there is a low
right lower quadrant
you might think of
appendiceal abscess a
secal carcinoma, ovarian
tumor. On the left
lower quadrant consider
diverticular abscess.
This occurs commonly
in diverticulitis that
there might be a
presence of an abscess.
In a sigmoid colon you
might have a sigmoid
carcinoma around in
that area or an ovarian
tumor. If it is
central, consider an
aortic aneurysm and
suprapugic if the bladder
is extended or there
is a uterine fibroid.
We will now be
looking into palpation
of the abdomen, how
it is conducted,
and any findings
that might present.
When palpating
the abdomen,
you want to first
do it lightly.
This is to identify
any areas of
tenderness,
muscular resistance,
and superficial
organs or masses.
This should be done
on all four quadrants.
Then you will proceed
to do palpation
that is deeply. Please
make sure that you
use the finger pads,
not the fingertips.
You want to attempt
to delineate with
this deep palpation
any masses if
there is such as a
pregnant uterus, an
abdominal aortic
aneurysm, or a
distended bladder.
These would be common.
If a patient
complaint is abdominal
pain this is a
reminder yet again make
sure you examine the
painful area last.
There are several
methods by
which you can
palpate the liver.
Here we show
bimanual compression
and here you would
place your left hand
under the right posterior
ribs and then the
right hand would
palpate deeply and for
the liver below the
ribs on the right side.
You can also palpate
the liver by a two
-handed deep palpation.
In this method you
place your hands
below both hands below
the rib cage and then
push upward towards
the head or cephalod
with both hands.
You can palpate
the liver also
by using the
hooking technique.
This one is you
take both hands and
place them from above
the patient to the
lower edge of the
of the rib or from
where you actually
palpated or percussed
previously the liver
at that area and
then hook the liver
in that fashion.
In the palpation of
the spleen while you're
standing on the right
side you brace the
posterior ribs with
your left hand and
then palpate the
spleen with your right
hand. You will ask the
patient to take a deep
breath as the spleen
is being palpated.
If the spleen is
enlarged you will
feel the tip of
the spleen when the
patient with the
patient's inhalation.
Palpation of the kidney.
This is a bimanual
technique, meaning that
you're going to use
both hands.
You place one hand
on the patient's
back parallel
to the 12th rib.
Then you lift the
patient's back and then
place your other hand
below the costal margin,
lateral and parallel to
the ****** abdominis.
Ask the patient to
take a deep breath.
At the peak of inspiration,
attempt to capture
the patient's kidney
between your hands.
Remember in this
one is you're going
to stand on the same
side of the kidney
being palpated.
So you can do the
right side first and
then the left side.
To palpate for
aortic pulsations,
you want to press
firmly in the
upper abdomen slightly
to the left of
the midline and
then you can from
there identify
aortic pulsations.
In persons over 50,
you want to try to
assess the width of the
aorta by pressing deeply
in the upper abdomen
with one hand on each
side of the aorta.
In this age group,
the normal aorta
is not more than
three centimeters
wide. This measurement
does not include
the thickness of
the abdominal wall.
The ease with which
you feel the aortic
pulsation greatly varies
with the thickness
of the abdominal
wall and with the
anterior posterior
diameter of the abdomen.
In an older person,
a peri-umbilical or
upper abdominal mass
with pulsations may
indicate the presence
of an aortic aneurysm.
When finding
tenderness of the
abdomen in any
of the areas
of the abdomen,
you want to try to
identify the possible
etiologies of that
tenderness. For example,
in the right upper
quadrant, in the area
of the liver and the
gallbladder, there might
be the presence of
cholecystitis might
be the reason for that
tenderness present.
In the left upper
quadrant you
may find peptic
ulcer disease
or even a pulmonary
pathology.
Epigastric can
be indication of
pancreatitis or
peptic ulcer disease.
Periumbilical can be
appendicitis, the same as
for the right
lower quadrant.
Suprapubic, you can
have bladder or uterine
pathology in the
flanks. That would
be for renal
pathology for either
pyelonephritis or the
presence of an abscess. In
the right lower
quadrant you can have
the appendicitis,
seagull diverticulitis.
In the left lower
quadrant you
might find sigmoid
diverticulitis
or even ovarian
pathology.
We can counsel
patients on
preventative measures
to reduce risk.
He re-selected
colon cancer.
Factors that are known to
increase the risk
of colon cancer
are excessive
alcohol intake,
cigarette smoking,
and obesity.
All of these
are modifiable.
Factors that can
decrease the risk of
colon cancer include
regular physical activity
and taking a baby
aspirin daily. The
United States
Preventative Services Task
Force recommendations
for colon cancer
screening is to begin
the screening at age
45 and continue until
age 75 years. You
can actually do colon
cancer screening after
75 years if the patient
meets the criteria
that's also listed
on United States
Preventative Services
Task Force website.
The CDC recommends
certain screening tests
such as stool tests
that are generally
done once a year. There
is also one called
Cologuard that is done
every three years,
sigmoidoscopy that
is done every five
years, and colonoscopy
every 10 years.
There is also CT
colonography that is
done every five
years. All of these
measures can be offered
to the patients.
Now let's look at
the osteopathic
consideration of
lower bowel disorders.
For the sympathetics,
you want to
consider T10 to
T11 for the right
side of the colon
and and T12 to
L2 for the left
side of the colon.
For parasympathetics,
the vagus would be
the innervation for
the right side of the
colon and the pelvic
splanchnic nerves
for the left side of
the colon. You can
also consider Chapman
points which would be
found at the lateral
sides of the thighs
in the anterior half
of the ilial tibial
bands bilaterally.
We started off this with
the case presentation.
Here is the complete
subjective of
this patient's
case presentation,
which was of a
patient complaining of
constipation that had been
worsening over the past
three to four months
she had complained
about having one to
two bowel movements per
week straining to ********
producing hard stools
and many time feeling
she does not completely
evacuate she's already
tried increasing
fiber and fluid eating
prunes and drinking
produce juice but none
of that has helped.
She did admit to
some weight gain but
denied nausea,
vomiting, diarrhea,
blood in the stool,
abdominal pain,
fever, chills, or
weight loss. And her
history shows that
she has hypertension,
vitiligo,
she had a history
of a bilateral tubal
ligation, c-section
twice, she has an allergy
to that produces a rash
if she takes it her
medications include
diltiazam 120 milligrams
which is to treat
her hypertension a
multivitamin daily she
takes docusate sodium this
is over-the-counter
100 milligrams daily
her social history she
does denies past or
present use of tobacco
alcohol or recreational
drugs. She does take
one to two cups of
coffee a day. She's
married, ******** active
with her male husband.
She works as a
pediatrician, reports
that she eats usually a
very healthy diet and
denies any stressors.
Her mother and father
are alive and well.
She has no siblings.
She has two
daughters and both are
also alive and well.
She had a mammography
and a pap smear this
year. Both were normal
and had her influenza
vaccine, the last one
in September of 2019.
In review of systems,
she denied fever,
chills, chest pain,
palpitations,
shortness of breath,
cough, nausea,
vomiting, diarrhea,
blood and stools,
black tarry stools,
regurgitation,
abdominal pain,
joint stiffness,
pain or swelling, rash,
tremors, paralysis,
depression, or anxiety.
Admits to fatigue,
weight gain,
and skin dryness.
this already starts
to point in one
direction of what are the
possible scenarios
or differential
diagnosis for her
constipation complaint.
Now let's look at
her the physical
examination, what
potential assessment
and differential
diagnosis and the plan
for us to consider.
her vitals are
as listed she is
slightly overweight
the rest of them her
vitals are stable
generally she appears
as stated aged well
groomed not in
apparent distress her
chest is clear to
auscultation heart is
s1 s2 is present with
a regular rate and
rhythm no murmurs
regurgitation gallop.
Her lung is clear
to auscultation
bilaterally, no wheezes,
rung eyes, or rails.
Her abdomen, you
find positive
hypoactive bowel sounds.
It is soft and non
-tender, non-distended.
You did not find
hepatosplenomegaly or palpable
masses no bruise
dilated veins no rebound
or guarding
percussion sounds were
tympanitic in all four
quadrants her extremities
there was no clubbing
cyanosis or edema
you did not see
varicosities they were warm
the pulses were two
plus times four her
joints had no synovitis
swelling or redness on
your skin exam you
found a rash there was
good turgor and you
did find dryness her
musculoskeletal exam
revealed good range of
motion for the upper
and lower extremities
for muscle strength it
was five out of five
for all four
extremities deep tendon
refurcals were normal
for all four extremities,
Romberg was negative.
On ****** exam you found
no external lesions,
her sphincter
tone was good,
no ****** masses,
the stool was soft
in the ****** boat.
On osteopathic
structural exam,
you found L1
flex side bent
and rotated and
side bent left.
Her guiac stool
was negative
and so was her urine.
So for differential
diagnosis, we can
consider hypothyroidism
that would correlate
with the presence of
Bertiligo is the two
of them can could
occur being that both
of them can have an
ideology of being
autoimmune we can also
consider irritable
bowel syndrome functional
constipation also
medication induced
constipation as calcium
channel blockers can
cause constipation
in fact in the elderly
it is very common
to have constipation
from calcium channel
blockers as well as
other medications.
She does have
hypertension
which is controlled.
She is overweight and
she does have a vitiligo.
These last are
all part of her
history except for
the being overweight.
In the labs,
we would want
to do thyroid
stimulating hormone,
check for anemia, do a
comprehensive
metabolic panel,
and check for
guaiac stools
times three to
make sure that
there is no
presence of blood.
Consider a
gastroenterology consult.
Consider discontinued
diltiazem
once lab results
are known.
You want to consider
the current medications
for now, counsel the
patient on weight
loss, discuss skin
care, use sunblock
lotions because
of the presence of
vitiligo, refer her to
dermatology, follow up
in two weeks, and
also discuss with her
getting the current
flu vaccine.
In summary,
you're going to
do the following.
Consider the
patient's discomfort
with discussing
their problems.
This should be
for any type of
complaint, but
there are complaints
that are more
sensitive to others.
Observe the
patient from the
right side of
the patient.
Not your right side, the
right side of
the patient.
Explain always to
the patient what
you are doing and
always inform them
of the results of
your examination.
Observe the patient
for signs of pain.
Don't rely on verbal
cues. There are
patients that are
very stoic and will
not verbalize, but
you can also see
that they're in pain
when you're doing
the examination by
looking at them.
these are the references
that were used
for this the preparation
of this lecture
they're all listed
under the respective
slide number for
you to be able to
look for additional
information if you
choose to do so I
thank you for listening
hope you all have
a wonderful day.
Please try to send out
a lecture feedback.
Below is the
link for your
availability.
Thank you again.